ciao nino benvenuti un nuovissimo b
ho visto che il video indovinano con
delle motivi era piaciuto un sacco ho
deciso di fare la seconda parte ho
trovato la versione delle cards che
aveva utilizzato per l'altro video music
edition quindi con tutti i nomi di
cantanti i titoli delle canzoni da
indovinare proprio come l'altra volta
però non posso giocare da sola cioè
sarebbe una challenge un pò triste
quindi l'altra volta c'è stato ed oggi
c'è ed offre go in esclusiva per la
prima volta giugno canale queste qui
dentro questa scatola che adesso aprirò
con molta nonchalance
ci sono delle card delle carte con un
riquadro giallo davanti con delle muse
che sono le mosse insomma che dovrebbero
farci intuire il titolo esatto
descrivere il titolo il gruppo musicale
eccetera eccetera dietro nel riquadro
rosso c'è il titolo la risposta esatta
la cosa più importante però è che
coinvolgeremo anche voi perché telefoni
alla mano
avremo a disposizione tre aiuti a testa
praticamente posteremo la carta nelle
storie e cercheremo di farci aiutare dai
nostri follower perché magari quella di
sposare non la sappiamo e quindi
ovviamente abbiamo bisogno di voi
metteremo dalla parte di ognuno di noi
quelle che indoviniamo così alla fine
poi le conteremo e vedremo chi sarà il
vincitore andranno che ci sia questa
volta c'è questa volta è stato un puro
caso il pareggio
ride o cd peppers gli a's ad ora apro la
procura protetta baby one more time
questa era per te mai loneliness hiskill
ami è bellissima ovvio è questa ed è la
anche questo non è un rebus thomas e
nolan ha una chance ma io sì io le mie
perché sto chiudendo gli occhi sempre
dante mescoliamo di confusione dei ruoli
una lei davide rai mai perfetto hotel
america hotel california come fate a non
lo so ma lo ricordate anche se è una
canzone si ok california è andata di
culo palesemente ragazzi forse questo
non dominerà il mighty negli occhi
chiusi selfin 26 surf papa c'è finiu e 6
ass
comunque siamo sempre pari ragazzi non
va bene che sa una cosa
ci puoi arrivare a catena in box
montagna ti ricordo che ai tre aiuti a
disposizione abbiamo tre aiuti a
disposizione quindi è arrivato il
momento di chiedere ai tuoi indovinano
subito chiediamo aiuto i followers ed ho
appena postato la storia quindi la
mettiamo qui in standby e andiamo avanti
bye bye maison musique by john kerry ma
che cosa sono sempre tutti ste robe è
facile facile su edreams sweet dreams
oppure are made of sweet dreams
veramente bella è vedere come la vedere
bellissima pronta
vedremo questa è aver indovinato
l'ho cantata due giorni fa la sfilata di
tezenis sta scherzando che mi hai fatto
la storia mentre ballavo i black and
yellow black and yellow black and yellow
black and yellow io non la conosco però
aspetta aspetta certo che certo la
conosco supera la conosco tanto candyman
no è una canzone anno
si assiste a me vuole insegnare è la
forbice no se lo chiedono i follower la
indovinano by allora la chiglia real mai
mai 2000 questa cosa indignato vediamo
se i mariners batteranno i 40 metti lo
dice senza farlo vedere ok questo è
senza la quale mettiamo qualche
facilissima green days green day green
dei green day è sbagliato
green dei green day cioè dai la beta che
sono buona facile guardo facilissima
radio rai e massaggio cosa gruppo
musicale si va massaggio ma non è un
massaggio mari relax ma no meglio ed a
10 20
io non lo sapevo red red wine come
faceva a saperlo
ma allora l'aveva letto cento per cento
si era anche facilissimo black indietro
edoardo qua gatta ci cova della donna
secondo me riguardo a cupertino un
indizio
no per niente penny street dai maker
stronzo wei wei se ti do un aiuto da me
lo perdonerei 32 e ovviamente guarda red
wine così va bene va bene cos'è la
strada cioè se tu la vedi direction
cos'è la privacy tu la vedi strada
autostrada statale ben pensilvania tempi
di arezzo ancorché canzone inizio con
penn
dai 66 questa cosa ma beni way of life
questa dovrebbe essere gare di un'altra
sbagliata nullo
ok non la so era penny lane quella dei
beatles una cretina però dai non era
immediato scusami rendering ben line ma
non era per line
allora io direi controlliamo un attimo
se i nostri follower hanno indovinato le
risposte allora mi dicono lollipop ma
non è un gruppo internazionale quindi
non credo suite ariana grande non credo
l'inter mix che le ragazze che ballano
il tango più una caramella
direi di no ecco le sugababes non era
quella io vado sul sicuro perché mi
hanno detto per forza sempre andrea che
però che era in realtà l'altra volta
grazie al nero aiuto da casa il mio
aiuto da casa dice linkin park e io non
posso che confermare perché sono un
cretino linkin park art
guarda ci devi pure pensare peperoncino
red
no pepperoni sparsi paesi twins e al
risto sexy diva e donna
dopo questa di default non siamo più
amici non ci vedremo mai più perché la
risposta era spice girl
sì sì sei rinnegato per sempre degli
amici vediamo sandei seguito di yoga la
tu sì è lei ad ora ovvero questa non
puoi non indovinare up da un gol
ripercorrendo i migliori anni della
nostra vita
queste carini a mombello abbiamo
difficilissima sia molto difficile dai
la meno aiuto questo che singolo eh non
lo fai anche tu rea non è non è un rebus
ah ok blasco sun non è un rebus corea e
ti posso dire che è il vostro all'ordine
questa canzone gang am style of a gun
gun side ad ora oa d'oro non l'hanno
visto che però guarda fire float ring no
cosa fai flooring hands of air flow ma
la sinistra dove ne hanno subito è
facile secondo lei che non è il tuo mood
non è il tuo genere in questo sospetto
di microfono bene ma giustificato direi
che tutto quello che facili da te quelli
che bari vediamo che hai mai che mai
[Musica]
spiega cosa comparti
manca una parola league
partirò music da risposta definitiva
partirò bis party rock sound partirò che
non party rock anthem questa era
difficile quella in cui era una canzone
è party rock anthem a lei lette da un
cielo per forza avere letto le note
musicali come di famiglie anthem x
perché mi ricordavo la canzone cioè mi
ricarica veramente non ho parole è la
costruiti così particolarmente come
diamo party partito
questa è una parola la sai ma la sai che
hai usato un sacco aiutami american
parti basi states non puoi non averlo
mai sentito dal lancio ad altri enti o
da esatto
secondo aiuto per marin terzo secondo
prego fire b b raf air fayre baby fi no
a 36 fino a sbagliata braga e libere da
forse adesso voglio vedere adesso
bisogna diventare più cattivi perché né
si avvicina latina
chase smokers agguerriti agguerriti
cavolo prego dai sella di ios
prego a proposito di top ma difficile
indovinerà mai mai top of the pops come
fai a sapere lei lette in futuro lei lei
sente vivo nella merda non è lei plan
dall'apparenza non ho parole guarda
veramente sono volto bellissimo dai
difficile e famosa cosa e famigerata non
famosa e ora chiede miners c'è questo
questo questa infatti vediamo anche a me
party in the us air la mia roba grandi
marine la se avete indovinato questa qui
e mi avete regalato un punto scelgo io
vabbè grazie no edoardo questo non vale
scusami eh ma dai non va male facciamo
una testa le giriamo così cioè scusami
non guardiamo non guardiamo sul don
guardia non guardiamo guardato però
tutte e due
facciamolo insieme vai io voglio vivere
la tua e ti renderai la mia
certo certo scissor sisters
cavolo vai dancing queen aspetta zio
mancano queste è la mia la tua questa
qua la tua ancora devono indovinare
e questa è la mia ancora devono
indovinare quindi vediamo
quest'anno ci sono top top vi ringrazio
perché avete regalato tre punti raga
grazie io
vediamo video hard sito a disposizione
due minuti dopodiché basta perché c'è
troppo aiutato troppo aiutato l'ultimo
check puoi saperlo scaduto non è vero
line bling york non ti posso dire
parolacce di video di mary fa un saluto
bray un saluto a drake e agli amici di
eduardo che hanno cannato tutti momento
della verità al momento del conteggio
l'altra volta avevamo pareggiato con un
18 18 bellissimo perché lui era convinto
di aver vinto io ero convinta di aver
vinto in realtà aveva pareggiato by per
il conteggio 3 21 18
io comunque sempre 18 edoardo ha perso
per poco noi siamo sportivi quindi è
arrivato secondo
ci hai provato
come circolo niamo questa volta io
aspettate qua allora incoronazione
ufficiale prego come fa miss italia
grazie grazie mille per questa vittoria
è importantissimo perché ero rimasta
molto delusa dal pareggio ma sono molto
sportiva e quindi regalo questa
fantastica corona di fiori hawaiana al
mio avversario è visto che gli voglio
tanto bene anche un microfono da
portarsi a casa per fare delle prove per
migliorare la sua conoscenza musicale
grazie per aver partecipato e ci vediamo
al prossimo video
se non lo avete ancora fatto iscrivetevi
al canale e chiedimi un bel like
commentate eseguite visto tutti gli
altri social facebook in sagra e tic toc
seguite anche do su instagram
vi lasciamo qua i contatti un bacione ci
vediamo al prossimo bene
si no
[Musica]